let's have a look at the first one now
as you can see on the boy I liked you
gonna treat to Mesa duties and then once
we're done I'm gonna ask you which you
think is the better way which do you
think was the one that you and choose in
the future now that you've seen both
blue here's the first way we're going to
do it and now if what I'm writing is
gonna be different to what you got on
your page which will be very very likely
based on what I've seen around please
also write by working next you're
working so you can compare both but even
if you have the right answer and I'm
reasonably happy with that okay here's
the first thing I'm going to do I want
to remember what these things actually
mean okay so this is three plus two bits
and this is two plus one fit right way
home right that's a bit
now therefore push number one is I've
got whole numbers and then I've got
fractions right each time I go holdup up
and the factor that's what mix new rules
are about okay so my first approach will
be I'm gonna do the whole numbers first
and then I'll deal with the fractions
okay so three take away two that's just
one yeah so I've got that bit already
and then I deal with this next bit which
is two-fifths take away a third do you
see that's the bit which I've got down
left over I've interested a lot of use I
think have done this in your heads or
you've got some rough working somewhere
else I'd love for you to have all of the
working there when I was up liking your
fractions tests which I'm going to give
out shortly one of the things I noticed
it I'm going to peek out I'll cover this
doing this so you actually I'm going to
peek out this page now what do you have
a look even if you can't see the exact
test you can see there's a sort of like
a bunch of righty there and it's not
really clear what order it goes in
there's a sort of go down this way and
then across so does this sort of go sort
of in a zigzag or does it go in a circle
which one is it okay
I'm not entirely sure that's because the
format of it doesn't make clear so you
can see I'm gonna go all the way down by
page
if you haven't set yours out like that
I'd love you to follow the way that I've
done it
I still got my one at the front these
two fractions then it talk the same
language so what shall I do with them
it's real
okay so I want to call it denominator
and the best way to do that is the
lowest common multiple of both
denominators 3 and 5
what's the smallest number that is a
multiple of both of them
15 perfect how do I turn this into a
fraction over 15 perfect so if I
multiply by 3 over 3
that'll be 6 over 15 is that look good
is that equivalent yeah and I also want
the other fraction to be 15 so what am I
going to do that one yeah
fantastic so that gives me this and you
can see that's why this is correct
because now that I've got this one
how many 50s am I left with just the one
of them right so lovely okay now let's
approach one I'm gonna show you a person
over to know which is to say remember
the first line he'll I dealt with the
whole numbers I dealt with them
separately you don't have to do that
he's another way you could do it so this
is approach number two go okay what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna take the hold up
bar and I'm gonna convert it into rather
than a big zero
what other fall can I convert it into
history improper very good because that
new bread is gonna be bigger than the
diet so here's the way I'm gonna write
my first lines of the write this as I
fifty plus two over five do you see
where those numbers come from is a 15
over 5 is the three that's out the front
the two out of five is the fraction that
was there in the first place
does that make sense by this okay what
will the second faction become I'm
trying to convert to improper one so
what will I have I'm ready yeah okay so
you've got to a theater which is correct
I should add where the seven over three
comes from is this gives me our six over
three and there's already or one over
three there yeah so I'm gonna write both
of those bits they're equals okay so now
I'm gonna put everything together in a
ball seventy two five seven over three
it's not ridiculously and then at this
point I kind of in this similar position
to here I want to get my chords
erroneous and there's still the same
code noise that I wanted from before so
I'm gonna multiply by three and what do
I believe I get to get over 15 by 5
which is 35
okay 51 takeaway 35 I think that's 16
yeah and you have a choice you can
either leave the other two like that or
you can convert it Cindy meets you which
is fine okay so two approaches which one
do you like
heads up who prefers approaching upper
one heads up
yeah most of you know I can't say thank
you kids down if you didn't prefer a
person of one that's okay
I push number two as you can see it got
us the right on top Oh what are you put
your hands up there why did you like
approach number one better
yeah because you mentioned a lot of
different things there I'm living focus
on that last one just look at the
numbers just look at the numbers that
I've written on the board clearly all of
these numbers are bigger numbers than
these guys up here right and that's
because I sort of included the three in
the two whereas here they just sort of
disappeared that dealt with it okay
because the joy suggests another reason
like it was like 532 really used the
first door yep instead of the second so
I don't have to be that big yep but the
second one the numbers that
yeah they were reasonable when we did
them all on the board together
Dirac so it's not like it's impossible
reach other dice you want to have one
last thought so you've done which
probability to get to the 70 yeah yeah
yeah good
well what I'm going to say is what I
think I like about this and I think the
kitchens you can do lots of different
things in fact this way we've confirmed
we've got the lining it's up both ways
that's kind of nice and of course they
rang we'd get calculators and tests you
could do that as another way good food
okay should move on is that okay
what are we to do is I'm gonna skip over
to I'm gonna go straight to three
because this one will have a
multiplication in it so if we focus on
that then we'll be able to get most of
those okay I'm just gonna drop this off
so we have a little more space to what
huh by the way are people happy with the
answer for to look at okay yeah so it
has the right vibe for me you can
already see under 35 there that's not an
accident where is that things like Tom
frog where is it sort of a murky Irish
yeah I try to get a common denominator
on time so I think Aidan did you read
with you you're in the sort of right
yeah so we can already confirm he's got
that right that's on the right page and
the rest of it will come just by testing
our let's have a go at this one so if
you haven't got some work in there this
is question 3
this is what we're after okay now again
just like most times you got lots of
different ways you can do this can
someone suggest to me our first line of
working that could actually help me yeah
does he question 3 yeah so what else so
what else you have a list up here yeah
6:05 ok so what we've done is we want to
have enabled this because you guys know
what this process is what have we done
it's not gonna say yeah we've converted
right so the conversion from a big city
rule to an improper fraction okay now
what took you take over okay so I'm
gonna change that into I'm gonna flip it
upside down and then what do I do with
it because that's a little bit over here
chief yes perfect okay so just like if
you divide by two that's the same as
multiplying by 1/2
that's why I've changed this into
multiplication and you can see here
because of this is the answer expecting
you're multiplying across which is
perfect okay
happy trips so well that Frank was you
wasn't it ok